please put your hands together for
Danielle Perez yes keep it over those
strong gentlemen keep it going for them
lifted me onstage I'm gonna hit them up
for a foot massage later when I'm on
stage and I'm performing
I feel really powerful what I'm saying
is being like telegraphed to all these
people that are there to hear my story
and be exposed to you know a Latina
who's disabled and in a wheelchair it's
just a really important thing to be
onstage representing that my name is tal
Perez and I'm a stand-up comedian
performing stand-up comedy while using a
wheelchair is a bit of a challenge
first of all people are always a little
they're just thrown off they don't
really get what's going on I'm really
excited to be here tonight just debuting
my new look which is aggressively fat
yet still very judgy I started comedy
three years ago I realized I loved doing
comedy after my first open mic people
laughed at me and that felt so good like
I wanted to hold on to that feeling
forever and I was like I need to do more
of this I'm a big girl but I can tell
that I've gained a little bit of weight
because people keep asking me if I have
diabetes which is really rude because I
was hit by a train I've gone through a
lot of dark things eating disorders
depression
I lost my feet when I was 20 I
definitely use comedy to speak about
those things but also to entertain and
through that find healing and myself
I think that comedy is really helpful
tool in healing and bringing people
together when you see someone on stage
that is sharing a story or telling a
joke and you're like oh I got that I do
that too it unifies and brings people
together and it's a form of catharsis I
go sit on my therapist about two years
ago but realized I should get back into
it when I started daydreaming about
walking into traffic and I don't have
feet I think the message that I want to
put out in the world is that it's okay
to be yourself it's okay to be weird and
different you're only given one
opportunity in this world so make it the
best you can
[Music]
you
[Music]